>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
CRITICS ARE CALLING A PROPOSED
PIPELINE PROJECT IN MEMPHIS,
TENNESSEE, ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM.
THEY SAY PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE BEING TARGETED
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
49-MILE UNDERGROUND CRUDE OIL
PIPELINE.
THEY'RE WORRIED IT MAY DEVALUE
LAND AND CONTAMINATE THECITY'S
DRINKING WATER.
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT AL GORE
RECENTLY WENT TO MEMPHIS TO
SUPPORT PROTESTERS.
THE PIPELINE COMPANY SAYS-HELD
FORUMS WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
TRY AND ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
WE SPOKE TO ADVOCATES ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS INTENSIFYING
FIGHT.
THIS GREEN ACRE OF LAND IN
SOUTHWEST MEMPHIS, CLYDE
ROBINSON CALLS HIS LEGACY.
IT'S BEEN IN HIS FAMILY SINCE
THE 1930s.
>> THIS IS THE WHOLE LOT --
>> Reporter: THE 80-YEAR-OLD IS
AMONG SEVERAL MEMPHIS LANDOWNERS
FIGHTING TO KEEP A CRUDE OIL
PIPELINE FROM CUTTING THROUGH
THEIR PROPERTY.
HE AND OTHERS LIKE SCOTTIE
FITZGERALD SAY THEY'RE BEING
ROBBED OF THEIR LAND AND
LIVELIHOOD.
>> THIS TO ME IS HURTFUL.
I AM OFFENDED.
>> Reporter: THE TWO ENERGY
COMPANIES OVERSEEING THE PROJECT
PLAN TO BUILD A PIPELINE ABOUT
FOUR FEET UNDERGROUND.
IT WOULD STRETCH 49 MILES IN
ORDER TO CONNECT TWO EXISTING
PIPELINES TRANSPORTING CRUDE OIL
TO THE GULF COAST.
THE COMPANY, PLAINS ALL
AMERICAN, SAYS THE PIPELINE IS A
SAFE, RESPONSIBLE WAY TO MEET
THE ENERGY NEEDS OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND THEY SAY THEY'RE PAYING
ABOVE-MARKET PRICE TO HOMEOWNERS
FOR ACCESS TO THEIR LAND.
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVISTS AND MANY
LOCALS SAY THE PIPELINE
COMPANIES ARE PRESSURING MOSTLY
BLACK PROPERTY OWNERS TO BUILD
THROUGH THEIR LAND WHILE ALSO
PUTTING MEMPHIS' PRISTINE
DRINKING WATER AT RISK OF
CONTAMINATION.
>> WE ARE FACING ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
RACIST PROJECTS IN THE COUNTRY'S
PRESENT AND HISTORY IN MEMPHIS,
TENNESSEE.
>> Reporter: JUSTIN PEARSON
CO-FOUNDED MEMPHIS COMMUNITY
AGAINST THE PIPELINE.
>> MEMPHIS IS THE LARGEST
MUNICIPALITY IN THE COUNTRY TO
SOLELY RELY ON GROUND WATER FOR
ITS DRINKING WATER.
THIS PIPELINE IS BEING BUILT IN
AN AREA WHERE THERE ARE KNOWN
BREACHES IN THE CLAY LAYER.
SO THERE ARE HOLES WHERE THIS
CONTAMINATION WOULD MORE QUICKLY
GET TO OUR DRINKING WATER SOURCE
THAN OTHER PLACES IN THE CITY OR
OTHER PLACES WHERE THEY MAY
OPERATE PLIIPELINES.
IT IS NOT TRUE THAT THIS IS
SAFE.
>> WE PICKED THE ROUTE WITH THE
FEWEST AMOUNT OF IMPACTS.
>> Reporter: PLAINS ALL
AMERICAN'S SPOKESWOMAN KATY
MARTIN SAYS 97% OF LANDOWNERS
HAVE AGREED TO THEIR PROJECT,
AND SHE SAYS PLAINS ALL AMERICAN
HAS TALKED TO RESEARCHERS AND
DONE ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES THAT
SHOW THE PIPELINE WILL NOT HARM
MEMPHIS' DRINKING WATER, SOME OF
THE CLEANEST IN THE NATION,
WHICH COMES FROM BELOW GROUND.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND PEOPLE'S
CONCERNS THAT THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR LAND?
THAT THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES WITH IN
PIPELINE?
AND THAT A MAJORITY OF BLACK
NEIGHBORHOOD IS BEING TARGETED
HERE.
>> I'VE LISTENED, AND OUR
COMPANY HAS LISTENED AND TRIED
TO HEAR EVERYONE'S CONCERNS.
WE'VE ROUTED THIS IN THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE WAY POSSIBLE.
WE AVOIDED ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES,
WE AVOIDED LANDMARKS, WE AVOIDED
DENSELY POPULATED NEIGHBORHOODS,
AND WE REALLY CHOSE THIS PATH
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO USE THE
VACANT LOTS.
IT WASN'T BECAUSE WE WERE
TARGETING ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
OVER ANOTHER.
>> Reporter: PLAINS ALL AMERICAN
HAS OFFERED TO PAY LANDOWNERS
FOR EASEMENTS TO ACCESS THEIR
LAND TO CONSTRUCT THE PIPELINE.
ROBINSON SAYS HE WAS OFFERED
$8,000.
FITZGERALD SAYS SHE WAS OFFERED
$3,000.
THEY BOTH REFUSED, AND NOW THE
PIPELINE'S LAWYERS HAVE TAKEN
THEM TO COURT.
>> SO EMINENT DOMAIN IS USED AS
A LAST RESORT.
WE ARE STILL TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
WITH EVERY LAND OWNER AND TRYING
TO COME TO A MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
AGREEMENT WITH THEM.
>> Reporter: ROBINSON AND
FITZGERALD DISAGREE.
THEY SAY NO AMOUNT OF MONEY WILL
PERSUADE THEM TO ALLOW THE
PIPELINE TO CUT THROUGH THEIR
LAND.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT HOW FAR
THIS HAS GONE?
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU TOOK
SOMETHING FROM ME THAT WAS A
LEGACY -- I HAVE GRANDCHILDREN.
HOW COULD YOU DO THAT?
I WOULDN'T THINK OF DOING
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING LIKE THAT.
>> THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
PIPELINE IS STILL IN LIMBO.
ONCE IT BEGINS, IF IT DOES, IT
WILL TAKE ABOUT NINE MONTHS.
ACTIVIST ARE HOPING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION INTERVENES SINCE
IT DID STOP THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE PROJECT.
THIS IS REALLY TOUGH.
THEY'RE CALLING IT ENVIRONMENTAL
RACISM BECAUSE THE MAJORITY
BLACK, LOW-INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD
IS BEING TARGETED, AND THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE, THE ONES
WHO OPPOSE THIS, SAY, YOU KNOW,
THIS COMPANY THINKS WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO FIGHT
THIS.
BUT THEY SAY THEY'RE BEING
UNDERESTIMATED, THAT THEY WILL
FIGHT IT.
THE COMPANY SAYS THAT THEY HAVE
THE ENVIRONMENT AND THESE
FAMILIES TOP OF MIND, THAT
THAT'S THE REASON THEY CHOSE
THIS ROUTE BECAUSE IT AFFECTS
THE LEAST NUMBER OF PEOPLE, IT
AFFECTS THE ENVIRONMENT THE
LEAST.
BUT FOR THOSE WHO LIVE THERE,
THAT'S 100% OF THEIR LAND.
>> YEAH.
ALSO WHEN YOU HEAR THEM SAY, OH,
THERE ARE ABANDONED LOTS THERE,
SO THAT'S WHY THE COMPANY WANTS
TO GO THROUGH -- YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF WHY ARE THERE ABANDONED
LOTS THERE.
IS THERE A HEAR OF LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN THE COMMUNITY?
IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE THAT
THAT'S A BLACK COMMUNITY IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
>> ALSO THIS COUNTRY NEEDS CRUDE
OIL, IT NEEDS ENERGY TO SURVIVE
AND TO CONTINUE.
THAT'S WHAT THE COMPANY IS
SAYING.
THIS GROUP DOESN'T WANT IT GOING
THROUGH THEI